foreign
in Phoenix is going to start off this
hour hey Jacqueline what's up
hi Dave thanks for taking my call sure
um so I'm curious if I'm on baby step 2
or baby step six
um my husband and I have saved for a
house and we had to down payment and
while looking for a mortgage my
grandmother offered to let me borrow
from my trust fund and the expectation
was that I would pay it back because she
doesn't want me to have my trust fund
until after she passes and so I've been
tackling the debt like it's baby step
two and my husband thinks maybe we
should just chill out a little and
chocolate like baby step six
you said you had a down payment for the
house previously is that correct what
was that down payment
40 you had 40 down payment and then you
borrowed from Grandma
yes okay how much did you borrow for
from her
all right 230 000. was that the rest of
the house
yes
okay
so you owe your trust fund for your home
yes
um
it's a bad baby step six
okay
so um how much is in this trust fund
um I don't know exactly but definitely
at least half a million
still after you took 200 out
yes
okay so the trust fund was left from
who to you
my grandma is leaving it to me is
leaving it so she's already oh she
opened she put the money in there while
she's alive for you her granddaughter
750 000. yes and then she agreed to loan
the money from the trust fund to you
what happens if you don't pay it
um Legally Legally
oh um I was told that I would just get
the balance of what's in the trust fund
so I wouldn't owe the trust fund any
money I would just get whatever's left
so you did not
legally do a lien on the house or the
trust fund that is yours could actually
foreclose on you
you didn't file a mortgage at the
courthouse
no
were there any paperwork signed
uh yeah
there was paperwork signed
yes on the loan
and it's more like just a document
between my grandmother me and a lawyer
uh I'm sorry say that again
it's just a document between me and my
grandmother and the document states that
you're to repay this at a certain rate
yeah it's just paying a certain dollar
amount every month until it's paid back
or until she passes is there interest on
that
no that's an interest-free loan
okay
um
I'm curious what what is Grandma's
reasoning for not giving you the money
versus lending it does she have yeah
which is what she should have done
um she just doesn't want me to have
access to it until after she passes for
some reason but she gave you access to
it
yes she did she's talking out of both
sides of her mouth
I guess she doesn't want my cousins and
siblings to also have access to theirs
I don't want to set a precedent
yes
that the others go well you did that for
Jaclyn
oh yeah now that makes a little more
sense I was getting ready to get after
Grandma here for a second
um
well it's maybe step six for sure to
answer your original question it's not
two it's a home mortgage it's just a
weird Home Mortgage agreed
yes okay there's no question about what
this is for what the money went to why
you have two hundred thousand dollars in
debt it's all about this house and if
you were to sell the house you would pay
off the mortgage if you were to
refinance the house you'd pay off the
mortgage which would be repaying the
trust fund that someday will be yours
anyway
yeah
um
okay I'm gonna get tacky are you okay
with that
how old's your grandmother I was going
to ask the same thing
uh like early 70s 72 73 maybe our early
70s
yeah okay how's your health
she's great okay so this is going to go
a while
no actually I mean we've been tackling
it like it's baby step two so I only
have three more years left on it but I
was just wondering like if I were to go
back to the agreed upon amount I could I
mean it would take it like four years
but I was just wondering I would do I
would do the agreed on Pawn amount for
four years
okay yeah because baby step two is is
gazelle intensity baby step six is you
move from intensity to intentionality
and
um what I would tell you there is put
fifteen percent of your income away to
retirement
um and baby step four save money for
your kids college and maybe step five
and any money you can get out of your
budget beyond that is extra payments on
the mortgage that's a normal
baby steps answer and I'm going to apply
it in this weird situation
okay yeah we just we've never had debt
because we grew up on the Ramsay plan
like our parents gave us your books as
we were kids so we've never had that so
we just we freaked out when we suddenly
hugged it yeah how old are you guys
uh 33 and 34. okay
yeah so are you putting 15 away in
retirement
yes
okay so you were already treating it
like and then above that you're paying
more than your normal
agreed payment
yeah and then we both have second jobs
okay I might back off on the intensity
of a reasonable life and pay the regular
payment and what you can above that with
having a reasonable life an intentional
life and then get rid of this
wow
there's only one thing keeping me from
saying grandma made a mistake here and
that's the precedent with the other
cousins yeah maybe she's got a crazy
because it does have well not me she
doesn't have a point there
um but uh see the difference in me
though is this uh we told our kids Fair
is where cotton candy and the Tilt aware
world are
fair is it's my money I decide what I
want to do with it that's fair and so if
I want to give your brother more I'll
give him brother more it's my money
um and so if your cousin called up and
said if I was your grandmother I would
do away with this loan because I think
it's weird it's icky it's strange the
borrower's slave to the lender I got a
weird feeling in my stomach talking to
you about it I don't like it so I would
pay it off and reduce your amount and if
the cousins come around and go no
I just stood there for her I'm not doing
it for you by the way it's free money so
you don't get a vote my money you know
you can just say No No's a complete
sentence and fear fair is where there's
cotton candy in the Delta world that's
not fair well my money
go visit the fair it's not socialism
it's capitalism this is the Ramsey Show